Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier
And welcome back to Resident Evil Banned Footage.
Now, apparently...
I'm dumb.
And I did, in fact, go through it backwards.
How was I to know?
Maybe I should have checked.
But I didn't, so here we are.
So I'm going to start with... Bedroom.
And I don't know how these- how long these are gonna take..
But we'll try.
*Mark reads the screen*
*sarcastically* Oh, good.
Was it a delicious cocktail of bugs and soup?
And also.. various organs?
Bedroom- Shit th-woah.
...
Ooooh no.
Poor Clancy!
Ya know, Clancy has been through so much shit!
Fingers cut off..
...burned alive.
Bad stuff in general.
Oh boy.
What do we have here?
Why am I here?
*door creaks* Oh!
Mom!
Hello~
A little bit, y'know...
Oh.
Oh okay. Great.
Not at all.
Not even a little bit, mom.
I jus- you know. Hey.
Oh!
Wha- *laughs* I-I... multiple choice.
Ohhh boy.
Oh boy.
Oh boy, oh boy, oh boy. Okay.
Wow, this looks delicious.
It looks delicious!
Hi.
*Uncomfortably* Yeah.
Okay! I'm gonna eat up.
Okay.
Alright, you know what. I-
Okay I was gonna, I'm just saying, like. I'm a hungry, growing boy!
*nervous laughter*
Alright.
Escape from the room? What are you talking about?
What about this delicious meal right in front of me?
Spooon.
*mocking* "I gotta do something."
*laughing* I'm going to put this in my mouth.
I gotta do it good.
Yum, yum, yum.
Eugh... well, that ain't gonna work.
Huh. Well, take two.
Here we go.
I'M A BIG BRAVE BOY!
I wanna impress my "mama."
I gotta see my new "sister."
Here we go. *starts laughing*
Well, I don't think this is working for me
but I'm going to keep trying at it.
I sure do love bashing my head against the wall.
And I sure do love mama's cookin'.
Oooohhh yes.
When they were asking what was cooking for a good lookin', that "good looking" was me.
See that. That's-that's... eugh.
Huh.
Okay.
Well.
*stuttering* I-I mean.
...
Oh, alright.
Y'know, that's an option too.
I thought I was going to be a member of the "family."
Eugh.
*Mark reads the screen again*
Oh, okay, I guess the food ain't good enough.
*grumpiplier* I thought I was gonna be a member, man.
Alright, so.
*mocking* "I gotta do something."
maybe i can
uh huh
okay
oh!
well that was easy
wai... what?!
i didnt even need to use the spoon?!
alrighty then
oo lantern okay
ooo i know where i am
is that a key?
maybe
ohh they set up a nice little poozzle for me
okay what have we got here
oh anything in there
ahaha
ahoho
ill take that
a strong pull might open it
but, a strong pull might also
same time as all the other clocks
well i know that
but do i know it here?
they may have changed it
oh
that was a nice pull
maybe broken okay good to know
probably shouldn't have opened that
because if there one thing i know about the puzzles from a previous thing
its that i shouldnt do everything
cant use that there
okay
so there gotta be
this where MY
superior searching skills from all
the training that I've had
ohh untitled painting B
gross
AH gross
i got a lighter
ugh ah they're aggressive
well okay alright then
what about with this?
how about i burn them?
you gonna get burnt?
AHHHH they're still angry!
need somthing hotter
okay
alright so.....
whats this...? HELLO!
*sarcastic* ah good
yes
dead rat
very fun
glad I picked that up
can i wash my hands
any clue on it?
NO?
anything up its ass?
okay
good
alright
great
glad I did that
oooh hello
some kind of door beneath it oh okay
that... that's -  I don't need to worry about right now
what was the time?
I'M SORRY
I didnt mean to
sorry ma
okay so what if i use
this on this?
looks like a key
alright then
is anything hotter in here?
ooh hello
ohhh what a nice painting
is that my future?
nothing mom
mom nothing
oh shiat
well that's not good
do I get... oh no the drawers open
I've also got a lantern
okay well
and uh thats a problem
well I...
I've goof-ed myself pretty hard here I think
I think we can all agree
that I've
I've done a few goofs
I gotta put the drawer
the drawers gotta be back
the lantern's gotta be on the hook
ya shouldn't've
shouldn't've uh
shouldn't 've done that
shouldn't've done that ah
shit it wont budge i shouldn't've
ahhhh shouldn'tve opened that
should've closed that
ohhh boy
should put this back
well thats not gonna work
ah alright should put this back
well alright then
I just....I've goof-ed hard and alot
I should put this back on the ring
oh come on
hi mom
what mom?
what?
what are you talking about?
oh no
mom!
ugh *vocalizing*
ahhhh
well that i got eaten alive by bugs
so thats good  so ya
wait am I still alive?
oh!
okay will do mom
will do, will make sure not to do no stupid
alright then well gonna get out of here
what if the drawer did open itself mom?
well
its firmly screwed in place
so how 'bout this?
okay so this time
without being a goof about it
I gotta be a little more stealthy
so theres gotta be
so thats closed now
is the lighter back in there? no its not okay
so that's all back in its place
ohh
ahh
ok
so now that I've got two paintings
I don't know where I stuffed the other one
how I hid it in bed, but now that I got two paintings
so there's got to be
ahh
there's three paintings
this one goes there
ah this one goes there
and ah this one goes there
oh
nice
ok
let me just close this book back up that'll be nice
can I close that back up? oh it's bleeding
alright well thats bleeding soo..
but this wasn't like this, so
I'm going to... take that off the wall
ooh, take that off the wall, put that back where it waaas,
aand, put this one back where it was
because I don't want to be caught again!
so I'ma put that back for now
just in case i gotta make a mad dash back to the bed
but now
I've got
a sewing needle
and so the SEWING needle
...can probably...
ooh
what is this?
there's like something else here
lantern hook is fixed by cork
huh...
so I need this to stay here for now anyway
but this is obviously something
this could be something to a shadow puzzle
like, say, a snake cuz it kinda looks like a snake
I've gotta find something else
so this had nothing in it, this is just a note
same time as all the other clocks
OOOH!
maybe if i use this sewing needle on the clock
Yeah
ok and then
what was it 10:30?
wait
what does that clock say
this lock says it is    NOTHING
this clock says    NOTHING
it is says 5 o'clock, ok
5 o'clock, ok that's good
5 o'clock it is then
i shoulda gone the other way but then again im dumb...so
let's keep going in this one
is it gonna bing bong? it might bing bong
this might bing bong
nope not that, not that, the other one
k put that back, that doesn't need to be there
oh boy
that ain't good
I don't know what that means
I dont know what any of that means so i just need to
yeah ok
NOTHINGS HAPPENIN' MOOOM
what are you talking about "nothings happenin"?
alright sooo, im just get back in because
I
I set everything back to normal right?
yeah
no no no ma
what are you talking about?
WAAAT?
crazy
crazy mom
im a good boy
mom I'ma good boy, you wanna see how much of a good boy I am?
hey ma
heeey
*gasp*
you brought me something else
did you?
you're so nice
thank you ma
ma
you so sweet, you shouldnt have
oh
uh...
ooh
really?
nothings changed
nooOOO, what are you talking about?
WHAAAT?
YEAAAH, that what I thought, thats what I thought
awwww, so sweet o' ya
so sweet, can i eat this now?
I got a fork tooo?
you're the best mom anybo..
ok anyway
so what have we got here
eww..
HA!
good to have a sense of humor right when ya
are about to die
oooh, snake fork
well I'm not gonna use that, but now
I should be able to light those, um
those critters on fire because now I have a stove
also I should be able to burn their entire house down
so that probably be a good idea but imana
I'ma take a, take a leave of absence on that just for now
cuz I...
...want to get out of here
k
so stove there
use a my item on the stove
lighter?
needs FUEL before you can light it okay
so I couldnt get downstairs just yet
and I havent exactly figured out this but...
was there an inscription on....